[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN BARRUS: And welcome to
the supercharge performance
session.
We're going to talk
about GPUs today.
How many of you have used
GPUs in a data center before?
Raise your hand.
Oh, quite a few.
That's good.
How many in the cloud--
used them in the cloud before?
OK.
So some of you had
the fun experience
of setting up your own GPUs.
And some have had the experience
of spinning them up and just
using them remotely.
So we're going to talk about why
people are interested in GPUs;
and we're going to tell
you about how GPUs are
available in Google
Compute Engine;
and remind you why you should be
so happy about it-- and anyone
that's set up GPUs before
should know that already.
And then I'll walk
you through how
you provision a GPU instance.
But the highlight of our
talk today will be three
demonstrations-- one from MapD,
who will be showing amazing
data analytics--
very fast data analytics
using GPUs in the cloud.
And then Schlumberger
is going to talk
about how they do seismic high
performance computing with GPUs
in Google Cloud.
And then we'll talk about
remote workstations.
So why don't we get started?
So this must be
familiar to most of you,
if you've done much scientific
or engineering work, or work
in machine learning,
you know a lot
of that requires
matrix operations.
And these matrices can be very
large, sometimes 1,000 by 1,000
or larger.
And the nice thing
about GPUs is they
can do some of these
operations in parallel.
So, for instance, multiplying
ax in order to get b--
each individual element
of a can be multiplied
by an element of x in
parallel, independently
of all the other ones.
But, of course, then
you have to gather up
some of that information
not quite as parallel
when it comes time to add
those together, but still very
parallel.
And the nice thing
about GPUs is they
have a lot of cores for doing
these operations in parallel.
So just a quick overview--
CPUs, typically,
have on the order
of dozens of threads that
can do these operations
simultaneously.
But GPUs have, in some cases,
two orders of magnitude--
100 times as many.
And so they can do these
calculations simultaneously.
And the other thing
that's nice with GPUs
is they have lots of
memory bandwidth--
sometimes an order of magnitude
additional memory bandwidth.
So if you have a lot of
data to churn through,
you can push data through very
quickly through those cores.
So I have a little animation
to show you how that works.
A CPU is very
flexible, can do lots
of different types of operations
on the data that flows through.
And it can scale up to dozens
of cores simultaneously.
So you can crank a lot
of data through a CPU.
A GPU has higher
memory bandwidth
so it can push
some data through--
streaming data
through-- more quickly.
And then can scale up
to thousands of cores
simultaneously.
So you can imagine, if you
have lots of operations to do,
you can do a lot more
work all at once.
So one example of that is AMBER
molecular dynamics software,
where you can do a simulation
of the interaction of molecules
together.
And this chart shows you that
in some cases, using CPU nodes--
up to 100 CPU nodes--
I'm sorry, 48
2-processor CPU nodes--
you can get up to
around 20 nanoseconds
of simulation per day.
So 20 nanoseconds everyday
takes a lot of days
to get up to a single
day of simulation.
With a GPU, you get 2 and
1/2 times that performance,
with three nodes of four GPUs.
And Nvidia was kind
enough to share
some data with us, our partner.
They have mentioned that
GPU developer interest
is increasing substantially.
We have over three
times as many developers
signed up now in
the past two years--
up to 400,000-- and
more than 20,000
organizations engage with Nvidia
for deep learning activities.
And you can see that the major
deep learning frameworks are
all GPU-enabled now--
accelerated by GPUs.
So what are the things
you can do with a GPU?
Raise your hand if you've done
some of these things-- machine
learning?
Who's done machine learning?
So a good number group.
Frame rendering
image composition?
A people here.
Physical simulation,
analysis, FEM?
A few people.
Real-time visual analytics
on a SQL database?
You'll see that one today.
We're going to show a demo.
How about faster-than-real-time
4K video encoding,
or transcoding?
We've got someone here
that's excited about that.
Sequence mapping, and
alignment-- or subsurface
analysis for the oil
and gas industry?
I should see some hands
from Schlumberger over here.
They'll be talking
about that later.
So, just to give
you some examples--
so we're going to be talking
about V-Ray today, where
we have more than 100 K80 GPUs.
That would be on the order of
500 teraflops of performance,
rendering massive
models in real time.
And then we're going to
show a demo of MapD's
real-time visual
analytics, where
they use a parallel processing
power and high-memory
bandwidth of the GPU to query
billions of rows at a time.
And I'd like to highlight
this quote, which
is also on our web page--
that single high-mem 32 instance
with eight GPUs was almost 100
times faster--
85 times faster--
than Impala running
on a cluster of six CPU nodes.
So that's an example
of real value.
So, as you know, we have
K80s available today in beta.
We've announced, and
will soon deliver,
S9300s from AMD and
Nvidia Tesla P100s--
a lot of enthusiasm for
the P100s coming out.
And right now they're available
in the US, Europe, and Asia.
And this, as I mentioned
before, offers teraflops
of performance per instance--
and especially for
machine learning,
engineering simulations,
and molecular modeling.
You can attach, as
I mentioned also,
eight GPUs per virtual machine.
And you can do either one, two,
four, or eight simultaneously.
We have them in
three regions today.
And then we have
another region--
US West-- coming online
within the next few weeks.
One thing that people
really like about the GPUs
in Google Cloud is that we
offer essentially bare metal
performance.
We're offering them through
passthrough mode, which
means they're directly
attached to the CPU
that your VM is running on.
So it's directly attached.
You get high performance.
And you can attach
to any machine type.
So you have a lot of
flexibility, as well.
And since we charge
only per minute,
with a 10-minute
minimum, you can
choose a GPU that
best fits your wallet
and, also, pay only
for what you use.
You don't have to
worry so much about
if you're using it for a full
hour or a fraction of an hour.
And then you don't have to
make a capital investment, too,
which is a huge advantage.
I think pricing is
available online.
But I thought I'd
mentioned it here--
that it's $0.70 per GPU per
hour for the K80s in the US.
And then Europe and Asia are
each $0.77 per hour per GPU.
Now here's the nice thing is--
again, people raised
their hand earlier.
If you've installed
a GPU before,
you know it's a lot
of work to do that--
buying the hardware,
waiting for it to arrive,
buying the system that
surrounds that, the networking,
putting it all
together, assembling it.
It doesn't work the
first time-- why is that?
Is the GPU bad?
Did I seat the card
correctly in the board?
It's really a lot of--
it's a challenge.
And you have to have
the physical space.
And the other thing
is hardware does fail.
Who manages the
fleet to make sure
that if the hardware fails,
it gets replaced and fixed.
But I think one of the biggest
things is power and cooling.
So if you're thinking about
running 100 GPUs somewhere,
those GPUs put out a lot of heat
into your data center, right,
or into the closet
you're putting them in.
And so you have to be careful
or you might install more GPUs
than your cooling system can
handle and, actually, not be
able to run at the
high performance.
We've taken care
of that for you.
So if you use GPUs
in the card, you
don't have to worry about
any of these things.
Just to step you through
what it takes to provision
a GPU in the cloud.
I was going to suggest that
someone get out their computer
and start putting together
a GPU machine right now.
You can start ordering
online to order a GPU
and see how long it takes you.
In the meantime,
we'll have a race.
We'll see how quickly we
can get one up in the cloud.
I think I'm going to win.
So you go to the GPU--
to the console.
And you choose the
Compute Engine tab.
And click on the
Create Instance button.
And then you can
choose Customize--
that's where the GPUs
are hidden right now.
Once you choose
Customize, you'll
see that you can choose
the number of cores
and how much memory you want.
And there's a little GPU link
you can click on underneath.
And you can choose the number
of GPUs you want and the type.
Of course, the type
right now is the K80.
And the number-- you can choose
one, two, four, or eight,
as I mentioned before.
Now if you prefer to
use the command line,
here's an example command
line for provisioning
a GPU instance.
And the main thing
to pay attention to
is the accelerator option,
with type and count
to say what you want.
So either one will
get you a GPU.
Now I want to mention, too, GPUs
don't support live migration.
Because we're offering
them in passthrough mode,
to get the high performance,
we don't actually
have the capacity to capture
the information in the GPU--
the current state of the
GPU in the memory, and move
that over to another
physical GPU.
So when it's time
for maintenance,
we notify you, give you
one hour notification.
And the GPU terminates
one hour after we give you
a notification.
And you can-- we'll give
you some support for that.
If you watch the
VM metadata, you
can see that if you
run this command
you'll get a none if
maintenance is not scheduled.
Or you'll get a time stamp that
says when the maintenance is
going to happen.
And so, based on
the time stamp, you
can either reboot right
away and get a new machine.
Or you can check-point
what you're working on,
save it, and bring it
back up in a new instance.
And I should have mentioned that
the information about how to do
that is online in this link.
And then, if you're
using TensorFlow,
we make it even easier.
You can use TensorFlow
as supervisor.
And that allows you to manage
banks of GPU-based VMs.
And it handles both shutdowns
and crashes cleanly--
easily resume, so you
don't lose any data.
Because especially when
you're doing machine
learning training, it might
run for weeks at a time.
And you don't want to lose
your work due to a maintenance
event.
So now I'd like
to invite Todd up
on the stage to give a
demonstration-- introduce
himself and give
a demonstration.
TODD MOSTAK: Thanks, John.
Hey, everyone.
Really excited to be
here today to tell you
a little bit about MapD, which
is a GPU accelerated database
and visual analytics platform.
And we'd really like to thank
John and the Google Cloud team.
We're tremendously
excited about what
Google is bringing to market
here, in terms of their GPU
instances.
There's a lot of
flexibility for developers.
There's a lot of flexibility
for startups like us,
to basically mix and match
components, and deliver
the perfect system.
So just a little bit about us--
we are a series A startup;
have some great investors--
including Google,
as well as Nvidia.
We've won some awards.
We were Garnter Cool
Vendor last year.
And have had a good
set of early customers,
including Verizon Wireless, who
I'll be speaking with at Strata
next week.
So everybody knows
that organizations
are awash in data.
So they're saying that
data growth is actually
40% year-over-year for
your average organization.
And storage is not
the issue, right?
So people can put
the data on disk.
They're building massive data
lakes, massive Hadoop clusters.
Storage is not the issue.
The issue is when you actually
want to analyze this data.
So if data is growing at
a 40% year-over-year rate,
CPU compute is
actually only growing
at a 20% year-over-year rate.
And so this compute gap
between the growth in data
and the growth in
CPU is causing people
to do all sorts of
unnatural things.
People down-sample,
people pre-aggregate,
people, basically, have to
deploy huge scale-out clusters
of hundreds, if not
thousands, of nodes,
with diminishing
returns of scale.
And so people are
at this impasse.
And that's where GPUs come in.
So I don't want to reiterate
what John has said,
but GPUs are not only fast,
but their processing power is
growing at a tremendous rate.
And not only is it keeping
up with the growth in data,
but it's actually surpassing it.
So whether you measure
by compute bandwidth
or by memory bandwidth,
you have a huge amount
of throughput on GPUs.
And I'd like to point out
that everybody pays attention
to flops--
and certainly GPUs
deliver there.
Actually, if you look
at the memory bandwidth,
that's almost more important
for data analytics problems,
where things are often
memory bandwidth-bound.
So that's where MapD comes in.
So MapD was built from
the ground up to leverage
the massive parallelism
and memory bandwidth
of these graphics processing
units, to literally deliver
100 plus x speedups over CPU
systems on a equal hardware
cost basis--
going back to that quote
that John showed earlier,
comparing us to Impala.
And so you can run
these crazy fast SQL
queries over billions of rows--
subsecond-- allowing,
for the first time,
truly interactive
exploration of big data sets.
And because one
of the killer use
cases is so often slice
and dice visual analytics,
we built MapD Immerse, which is
the web-based visual analytics
engine, which not only leverages
the speed of these GPUs,
but the ability of the
GPUs to render graphics.
So we sort of use it
as a one-two punch,
where we can run the SQL
query over billions of rows.
And because you often don't
want to actually transmit
all that data back
to the client,
we can actually render it
in situ right on the GPUs,
using the graphics
processing pipeline,
and render it in place and
send back a compressed PNG.
So with that I'm going to
cut to a quick demo here.
OK.
Can everybody see my screen?
Great.
So this is a relatively
sizable data set.
This is 2 billion records.
Basically all the ship AIS,
or ship transponder data,
from throughout 2015.
What's notable
here is that we're
running on a single eight K80--
or eight GPU 4K80--
Google Compute instance.
So if you tried to imagine
the amount of compute
you would need to
bring to bear to allow
interactive querying on this
dataset on a CPU cluster,
it's pretty amazing we're
doing this on a single node.
So you'll see all kinds of
different metrics here--
number of unique ships;
histogram of vessel link
destinations; here's
actually the ship ID,
so we can drill down to
individual ship; speed,
vessel type, time.
And then, last off,
you have this map,
which is actually all the points
color-coded by the vessel type.
So this is an example of
MapD's back end rendering
capability, what we call
our Iris rendering engine.
You wouldn't want to actually
send 2 billion records
from your server to your client.
So we actually render and
rasterize that on our back end,
on top of the SQL query,
almost as a visual UTF.
And then spit out a PNG, an
interactive PNG, to the client.
So the cool thing here is that,
actually, as I zoom in here,
you're going to notice
that, basically--
I'm going to go
into the Bay Area--
everything updates in real time.
And, actually, each
one of these charts
is hitting the back
end with a query
that's probably responding in
about 30 or 40 milliseconds.
And that's why we can
be so interactive, even
at this scale, even on a single
node, because we're leveraging
the power of these GPUs to,
basically, brute force these
queries, and answer them
in a fraction of the time
you could on a CPU-based system.
So, as I zoom in here,
I can look, you know--
what if I actually wanted
to see the fastest vessels?
So I'm going to kind of
cross filter here and look
at a number of records
here where people
are going at about 20 knots.
And then I can see
all these records.
I'll notice, first off, that--
if I increase this
even farther--
most of the fastest boats
are actually passenger boats.
So I could drill down
into that and we'll
see these passenger boats.
And then I could actually
find an individual boat here,
and drill down and, actually--
we could even zoom in and
see their exact tracks
across the Bay Area here.
So it's a pretty fun data set.
And you can, again,
get very granular.
So if we actually go
off and look, basically,
out into the Bay,
you can actually
see where the tankers sit.
And they circle here and they
moor, which is pretty cool.
I'm going to quickly
show you one other thing.
How am I doing on time?
Let's see.
OK.
Just two more minutes.
So we not only built MapD, or
our Immerse visual analytics
platform, to be
fast, but we also
built it to be very easy to use.
So what if I wanted to
explore the relationship
between speed--
let's see, here.
I'm going to go to scatterplot.
What if we wanted to look at
the relationship between vessel
length--
and we'll put that
on the x-axis--
and speed, which is SOG here.
So we immediately
have the scatterplot.
And, again, this is
actually leveraging
the power of the GPUs to
do this on the back end.
And here, for good measure,
I'm actually going to color
by the type of boat.
So immediately here you can see
that the bigger the boat gets--
the longer the boat
gets-- the faster it goes,
except the smaller boats--
the slow ones are
the tug boats here--
but the longer ones are
passenger and other types
of ships.
So I could easily build on this.
If I wanted to, I could add
another chart and cross-filter.
But it's very interactive
and easy to use.
And this kind of interactive
data exploration at scale
is something that
MapD really excels at.
So, thank you.
Good job.
[APPLAUSE]
KANAI PATHAK: Hello.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Kanai Pathak.
I'm from Schlumberger.
How many of you attended
the keynote speaker speech
this morning?
All right.
Quite a few.
So you heard our CTO,
Mr. Ashok Belani,
talk about the high-performance
computing work in oil field,
and our history of
using CPUs and GPUs.
And so we're going to talk
about how we are using now
GPUs in-cloud.
And thank you, John,
and thank you, Google.
It has been an exciting
journey so far.
And we're just
getting warmed up.
All right.
So Schlumberger-- very
briefly, what do we do?
We provide insight
into subsurface--
everything below the earth
and the layers and structures
and where the hydrocarbons are.
This is the sort
of services that we
provide to our customers.
We are technology company.
And so high-performance
computing, especially,
is quite relevant
to our one service
that I'm going to talk about,
which is the oil exploration.
And we call it, you
know, seismic processing,
seismic acquisition.
All right.
What's interesting for us,
as computer scientists,
is the volume of data that we
acquire, the volume of data
that we need to process.
And for that we have massive,
high-performance computing
centers around the
world, just dedicated
for seismic processing.
These centers have been--
they hold everything from
building to [INAUDIBLE] space
to CPUs, GPUs, storage.
And we've been doing that
for quite a number of years,
quite successfully.
So you can look at the
volumes of the amount of data
that we acquire and amount of
data that we have to process.
It requires-- so it requires
a lot of computing power.
And let me talk about
the seismic exploration
in a very brief two steps.
Step number one--
we acquire data.
And, as you can see, we acquire
a large amount of data per job,
or per project.
And we cover kilometers
and kilometers square--
[INAUDIBLE] kilometers
of area around the globe.
Step number two is
to process, to build
this sub-surface
understanding of what's
really going on down there.
That requires massive
amount of computing--
millions of cores,
millions of GPU-- well,
millions of threads and GPUs.
And it is the classic,
high-performance computing
that we've been
doing for many years.
So the question we start asking
ourselves a couple years ago--
and prior to that,
perhaps, a little bit--
can we do this massive parallel
computing in-cloud effectively
for business?
Can we do it for
all the workflows
that we need to do in seismic,
not just one or two algorithms?
And the answer
is, today, yes, we
are doing commercial work
in Google Cloud using
computer [INAUDIBLE] with GPU.
Without that, it would
not have been possible.
How do we do this?
I'm going to invite my
colleague, Carlos, to talk
about that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CARLOS BONETI: Thank you, Kanai.
CARLOS BONETI: All right.
So how do we do
seismic processing?
We have strong requirements on
dynamic resource allocation,
data management,
and fault tolerance.
This is because of the nature
of our business, the way
we do processing, right?
And because of
these requirements,
we try to avoid using MPI
or most of the classic HPC--
high-performance
computing-- frameworks.
So a few years back, we
built our own software stack
for our own data centers.
And that stack provides
a map-reduce-like kind
of infrastructure that
introduced sufficient amounts
of fault tolerance and
dynamic resource management
and it contains-- so, for
doing this, it contains,
basically, has its own custom
job scheduler and custom
resource and data
management layers.
As we brought that
software stack
that we built for own data
centers into the cloud,
some things were
familiar-- like,
for instance, the
Nvidia K80s, right,
which provided great
performance per dollar.
And other things were
essentially opportunities.
So some of those
opportunities were the ability
to dynamically create
instances, dynamically adapt
the VM's characteristics,
to match the performance
requirements of the jobs.
And some of those were--
like, for instance, the needs
for monitoring and control
were a opportunity disguised
as a challenge, right?
So in the graph here,
you will notice--
I know you can't quite
read the details--
but you'll notice there are
three main layers on this,
right?
On the top layer, you
have a very small number
of nodes, which
contain what I call
the durable infrastructure.
These are the pieces that make
the virtual data center work.
It's a small number of nodes,
like the job controller.
Now the middle layer is the
bulk of the data center,
is the bulk of--
are the compute nodes.
These are what we call the
ephemeral infrastructure.
And they basically live
for the length of a job.
You create those
nodes on-demand--
sized and dimensioned
for what your job needs.
And the bottom of the
layer is basically
composed of a parallel
file system that
feeds the data through
those to the compute nodes
and has a lifecycle that is
independent of the other two
layers.
Now, finally, what we have is--
we call it the FAT
link-- it's a 20 GB link
between our data center
in Houston and Google data
centers.
And that allows us to,
basically, upload--
well, move data, the massive
amounts of data that we have,
between Houston and--
between our data center
and Google, right?
And when I say a massive
amount of data-- basically,
a job commonly requires 60 to
100 terabytes of input data
to start running.
So to give you an example--
in this case here, we
have a single imaging job.
So this is running
reverse-time migration
and lasts for a few days.
We run it last weekend.
This was probably
about three days.
And, as you can see in the
curve here on your right--
on your left-- it
starts with 20 nodes
and it acquires nodes
as it scales up.
So at its peak, It has a little
bit more than 1,700 nodes.
And then it ramps down
as it finishes the work
to be done, right?
So I really get
excited about this kind
of problem because
of the massive scale
of these computations.
So, at the peak, we are
using about 7,000 GPUs.
And they're using something
around 20,000 CPUs
for that single job.
Now this is not the only
job that we're running.
Right?
Oh, and by the way, we're
generating about 220 gigabytes
per second FIO, combined.
But, again, this is not the
single job we're running.
And it's not unusual
that we run multiple jobs
at any given time.
As a matter of fact, if you
look at the other graph--
the green one--
you'll see the utilization
curve for what we are calling
our virtual data center, right?
So it's the footprint at Google.
And as you see, you have periods
that have about 50 nodes.
And they go from
50 to 5,000 nodes
within two or three hours--
which, well, I find
it's very cool.
So, to conclude, I
would like to reveal
some of the
opportunities we found,
which was the ability
to basically use
the GPUs that are
familiar to us,
that provide great performance.
And the ability to
resize and dynamically
create and delete VMs on demand.
So we create-- as
a matter of fact,
I think we create, usually,
a few thousands VMs per day,
create and delete.
And that comes with a price of--
you have to be obsessed
about organizing, monitoring
and control your center.
But, by leveraging
these opportunities,
we have successfully deployed
a virtual data center--
what we call a virtual data
center at Google, which
uses thousands of CPUs
and GPUs everyday, and do
massive seismic processing for
production workloads today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- You can introduce him now.
No?
What's that?
[INAUDIBLE]
ADRIAN GRAHAM: No, it's okay.
I got it.
No, I don't need--
I clicked myself.
Hey.
How you doing, everybody?
Everybody can hear
me in the back?
Mic's OK?
Excuse me.
Sorry.
My name's Adrian Graham.
I'm a Cloud Solutions
Architect at Google,
in the Venice office-- that's
Venice, California, not
Venice, Italy.
Although the food in the
office is still pretty good.
And I come from a background--
a visual effects background.
I spent 20 years as a pipeline
TD, and as an effects artist,
at companies like
ILM, Digital Domain,
Double Negative in London--
I worked on some big films.
And rendering is one
of the big components
of working on any film.
And that's what we're
going to look at today.
We're going to look at what a
renderer can do in the cloud,
and what it can do,
furthermore, on the GPU.
So what does a renderer need?
What is-- the role in
the pipeline of somebody
who's a renderer, or who
performs rendering actions,
is a lighter.
And they take all
of the assets, all
of the massive
amounts of data that's
generated by modelers and
texture artists and animators--
and those are simple assets--
the complex assets are
things like simulation data,
and complex character rigs,
and massive environments,
like if you have to lay
out an entire city--
the island of Manhattan
could be all completely
virtually generated.
And what do you do
with all that data?
And how do you move it
around and shift it?
So the render-- the lighting
artist will take all this data
and they'll make a
beautiful image out of it.
And they'll use a renderer.
Today we're going to look
at a renderer called V-Ray
by Chaos Group.
But to step back, what does a
lighter need to do their job?
They need a very
powerful workstation--
not a laptop.
You need multicore, good GPUs,
lots of memory, lots of RAM,
and lots of disk storage--
all these assets
that are generated
prior to the lighter
getting their hands on them
take up massive
amounts of space.
And as the data's coming
in, the data's going out,
a lighter is generating frames.
We don't render movie files.
We render individual frames--
24 frames in a second--
that's 24 images.
And they could be HD
res, they could be 4K,
they could be 8K, that
could be stereo pairs.
Massive amounts are required.
You need licensing.
You need to be able to
license the software
on the workstation, as
well as the render boxes.
You need color accuracy,
so that everybody's
seeing the same picture.
And, of course, you need as
many render workers as possible.
Now that's the
classic description
of a lighting pipeline.
Today we're going
to look at a project
by our friend Kevin Margo.
Kevin is a-- let me
just play these guys--
Kevin is a VFX supervisor at
Blur Studios in Los Angeles.
And Kevin did this short
film called "Construct,"
or "Construct," however
you want to say it.
It's about this robot
construction worker,
who shows up on the site one
day to find something horrible
is going on.
You could see it on YouTube.
It's a really great short film.
But on the right hand
side of your screen,
you're seeing the making of.
Now Kevin had some pretty--
he's this visionary director.
He's got some pretty
interesting ideas
about how to do virtual sets
and virtual motion capture
sessions.
And you could see
the guy in the suit--
Darren Ross-- he is wearing
a motion capture suit
with points on it that are being
tracked by a bunch of cameras.
That data is being fed
into 3D Studio Max,
which is the 3D application,
and being rendered in real time
by V-Ray--
V-Ray RT, in this case.
In the video, you'll also
see Boris, right, Simandoff,
who's in the audience
today with us.
Boris is the director of
V-Ray Cloud and IT at Chaos.
Did I get that right?
Thanks.
There's also some pretty
revolutionary cinematography
techniques that
Kevin has figured out
and that they're using
a virtual camera.
There's no real-world camera.
It's CG-- it's a
camera that is simply--
that rig that you
saw with the screen,
tracked by the director.
So that you could really
visualize what's going on
and what it's going--
the final result is
going to look like.
That also means that
you're not storing
massive amounts of data.
You're only storing
the positional data
for the camera itself.
Now this is the on-set
preview on the right-hand side
that you're watching.
But on the left-hand side,
that's the final render.
The final render,
in this case, they
tried a bunch of different
ways to render it.
They used CPUs-- each frame
took about two to four hours
to render.
And they tried GPUs.
And this is a couple of
years ago, so there was--
the setups were a lot different
and they didn't have the power
that we have on GCP.
And those renders took
about 18 minutes or so.
So what if we could do this
on a Google Cloud Platform?
And let me stop these guys.
Well, it just so
happens that we can.
So, before I start, I'm
running a remote workstation.
I'm not running
Windows on my Mac.
I'm running a remote
workstation in Us Central,
which is in Iowa, which is
about 1,500 miles away--
40 millisecond, round-trip ping.
And this is the full
scene that you see there.
And I am going to track around
a bit and show that-- oh,
I'm sorry, my mouse wheel is
a little bit wonky there--
but I'm going to zoom out.
This is operating over internet,
so it's a little bit slow.
But the render is happening
almost in real time.
And you've got to
remember how much data is
being generated in this scene.
Each of these-- it's doing
geometry substitution
on the fly.
Each of those red pyramids
is being substituted
for a full-resolution tree.
And you could zoom
in to the forest.
You could select a single
object and zoom in on it.
There's the dumpster.
I can go back to--
let me just go
back to the robots.
And the whole idea
behind this is not just
to move around your scene.
But you can change lighting,
and you can change animation,
and you can change
shading qualities.
Step back one more--
just want to make this a little
smaller so I can see my robots.
And there we are.
My robots seemed to
have disappeared.
But you guys get the idea.
Oh, there we are.
Let me just show the entire--
these live demos.
All right.
So I have hosed my demo.
But that gave you an idea of
what's going on in the cloud.
Come see me after.
I could get it running again.
So how do we do this?
This is sort of
a little bit more
complex architectural
diagram of how we did this,
what we're doing right now.
For example, we're not doing
any asset management database.
We're not syncing our cloud
directory user database.
But we're using
something called--
we're running over
Teradici PCoIP, which
is PC over IP, which is a remote
desktop protocol developed
by a company called Teradici.
And you can run this
on a piece of hardware.
This is zero client, which
just has a bunch of video outs
and an ethernet
port and some USBs.
And there's also
a software client,
which is what I'm
running on my Mac here.
There's one for Windows.
And there is one
for iOS devices,
as well, which is pretty cool.
Boris has it running
on his phone.
It's not even iOS.
It's Android, right?
Or running in a browser.
We are also running
a remote machine
running 3D Studio Max and a
bunch of render instances.
The render instances are
running Linux CentOS 7.
And, as you saw, unfortunately,
the interactive remote desktop
machine is running Windows--
an ancient version.
I apologize for that.
There are some plugins that
I don't want to talk about.
And then there's
a license server.
I'm running a Linux
license server
that's feeding licenses to
both the render instances
and the remote desktop.
And, of course, we're
rendering using V-Ray.
And those are licensed
via the cloud as well.
So how do we set all this up?
Quite simply, first, we want
to create a workstation.
And there's three
important points
I want to indicate
on this slide here--
is that, number one,
we choose our zone.
And, as John said
earlier, it's going
to be available in a
number of different zones.
West-- US West is
coming up very soon.
Had it already been running,
we would be running there.
The ping time would
be much faster.
You choose your GPU type.
Obviously, we have
our K80s right now.
And you choose your image.
GPUs can attach to
an instance running
any one of our public images--
different flavors of Linux and
different flavors of Windows.
So that's our remote
display workstation.
Oh, and, finally, we want to run
an agent, which will allow us
to run the Teradici protocol.
Then we want to create
a render worker.
But we want to create
the perfect instance
that we will then replicate
in a managed instance group.
So the two important points
here are, one, they're
in the same zone for
maximum throughput.
And, two, we don't
delete the boot disk
when the machine goes away.
And I'll show you why that is.
So you set this
machine up perfectly,
with all the software, the
hooks, and the licensing
that you need.
And then you take it down
and you save the disk.
And you turn it
into an image, which
gets turned into a template.
The template gets deployed
across your managed instance
groups.
And the final
important point here
is that you're running
a startup script when
each of these machines boot.
So we want to run the
V-Ray stand-alone server
mode-- which, you can see here,
runs on a particular open port.
And that means that we can take
from a list of these servers.
These are all the machines that
3D Studio Max is rendering on.
And so once the
machine boots up,
you can use a command to
view the serial port output,
to watch the progress
and to troubleshoot.
And, finally, we launched an
entire, managed instance group,
which is completely dynamic.
You could size it up or down.
If you want to
minimize your costs,
you start with only two CPUs--
or, sorry, two VMs.
And then, once it's ready,
you deploy another 30 of them.
And as long as the IPs are all
fed into your render options,
the renderer will
start to expand and run
on all these machines.
It's unbelievably powerful.
So when you think
that these things--
these frames-- took two to four
hours on CPUs, and 18 minutes
on older GPUs that were on
a different type of Nvidia
cluster, we're getting almost
real-time performance here.
Finally, there's
some helpful commands
that I use all the time, too.
For example, in the
top section here, I'm
tailing the serial port output.
And on the bottom, I can view
all of my running instances
to get an idea of where
their IPs are and everything,
and to see their
status-- whether they're
being terminated
or whether they're
coming up or still booting.
And that is pretty
important when
I want to resize
my instance groups
or stop the entire
group entirely.
I think we're
going to finish off
by what John was
saying earlier is
that the P100s, which
are display capable,
are coming soon--
very, very exciting.
And the AMD cards, as well.
I don't know the
specifics behind that.
But, just to summarize
what we saw here today--
we're running
V-Ray RT, by Chaos.
We're running 3D Studio
Max on 128 K80 GPUs--
there's 32 instances
each with 4 GPUs.
And we're running over
Teradici PC over IP
in a software client variant,
all running on a single Google
central1 region.
40 millisecond
round-trip latency,
and it's 1,500 miles away.
So all this is happening
in the cloud right now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN BARRUS: Thanks, Adrian.
So let's see--
what do we want you
to remember, from the takeaway?
First of all, thank
you for everyone
that came up and gave a demo--
MapD, Schlumberger,
and Adrian from Google,
showing how V-Ray works with 128
K80s running at the same time.
So fantastic, and fun demos.
And, I guess, what I
want you to remember
is if you want performance
that's scalable and--
come to Google Cloud and
fire up a bunch of GPUs.
And thanks for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]